make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay we are back to covering the boys
mariah is sitting in the next room
surfing on her MacBook Air I'll be
honest it's got a weird recording audio
in front of Mariah anyway so we are
covering the boys in a previous video
and those been a little while since we
cover the boys because like we were
moving and everything but now that we're
back into the swing of things the boys
will return as it normally does every
Tuesday actually there's one thing that
I want to add on here so lock press
nurse said today's his birthday and he
wanted a shout out so happy birthday LOC
and actually I was tagged in a tweet by
the page Crusader who had this really
cool video called page vs. film's Civil
War it reminds me a little video series
that I used to do called film vs. comics
whatever it is use that name dude if you
want to just run with it I'll probably
never make those videos again but in any
event the video was pretty solid make
sure you guys go check out this channel
down in the description so yeah the boys
okay so in one of the previous videos we
had talked about how we got this kind of
origin right but the origin only came
from the perception of the legend in so
far as how superheroes came into
existence so on and so forth what this
does is it gives us the same sort of
scenario but from the perspective of
Gregg Mallory now if those you guys who
don't remember Gregg Mallory was the
leader of the boys before the current
iteration picked up right so when the
boy series officially starts the team
had kind of been disbanded for some time
and Billy butcher was going around and
re gathering the team and and so on and
so forth Gregg Mallory was the leader
before that happened and so for those
who guys who were unfamiliar that the
way this played out is that the boys had
become a pretty heavy hitting team right
and we'll talk more about this as we
sort of get through this but the boys
had become super heavy hitting and the
result is that they drew the wrong kind
of attention and so ultimately things
popped off between themselves and the
seven and then Lamplighter who was a
member of the seven killed Gregg
Mallory's granddaughter but the result
is that Gregg Mallory cut him in hands
off ever since and so in the last video
that we did basically here we had taken
off back home and then Rick Mallory had
been contacted by mothers milk to keep
an eye on Huey and that's why the two of
them encountered each other in the first
place now that's kind of stated right
off the back when Huey figures out that
this guy is Gregg Mallory he asks like
why are you keeping an eye on me and he
says because mother's milk asked me to
but the big thing that comes out of this
is he really kind of starts to paint
this picture that Billy butcher is not
who he thinks he is right and by
extension us is the reader that Billy
butcher's not who we think he is right
because we look at Billy butcher and we
see him it's kind of a pretty extreme
guy right the guy's not totally off his
rocker but he is still kind of extreme
but we also see him as a guy who's
basically fighting the good fight the
picture that's being painted by Gregg
Mallory is that's not really the case
and that billy butchers actually for the
most part totally insane and off its
rocker which i guess we kind of knew but
the overall gist behind this is that
with the conversation taking place
between the two of them the clock
basically winds back to the Battle of
the Bulge right now the Battle of the
Bulge for those you guys who don't know
your World War two history the Battle of
the Bulge was probably the 3rd bloodiest
conflict the United States had ever been
involved in and I believe was the
bloodiest conflict of world war two
involving the United States but
essentially it was the last major
offensive of the German army it was
basically the Germans going for broke
right it's like if we don't win this and
we lose the war and that's exactly what
happened but during the Battle of the
Bulge at the time Gregg Mallory was a
captain in the military and so that's
one of the things to remember here is
that we do have these huge amounts of
time right because we are talking after
2001 and so this basically means that
this guy was a captain in the military
and then 51 years later still looks
pretty young now the result of this is
that really it's just a byproduct of
taking compound v is it basically slows
your aging but the fact remains that
during this time ultimately bought
American had basically sort of rise into
prominence now if you guys remember
during the previous Origen video that we
did bought American that first started
making a name for itself by producing
weapons producing tanks arms and
armament different things like that the
problem is that they were your standard
American corporation right so cutting as
many corners as they could and try and
amass profits as fast as they could the
result is that they created a whole
bunch of really really shoddy products
and had their weapons contracts pulled
and so as a result of that they seem to
kind of go under and nobody really heard
of them for for quite some time
this is when they basically resurfaced
and suddenly like they have superheroes
out there now what they do here is they
present a group this basically referred
to as the avenging squad right now you
would look at that he would say based on
the name they're more akin to the
Avengers and to a degree they kind of
are but given the time period they're
really more akin to the invaders right
so a name of the Submariner Captain
America the original human tourists Jim
Hammond and Bucky Barnes is really kind
of more of what they are with a couple
of Avengers concepts peppered in right
like Vikram's and countess basically The
Scarlet Witch but nonetheless the team
has brought in for the purpose of saying
hey look this is the next stage in
warfare and Vaught America has shown up
here on the field basically saying we've
got these super-powered individuals
right that can run really fast they're
they're really really strong so on and
so forth so much so that a couple of
them actually managed to lift up the
back of a tank now the funny thing about
this is that where Greg Mallory looks at
this he says okay so like from like a
face on perspective right like a surface
view yes it looks cool right they look
strong
look hit will they look anything you do
all kinds of stuff here's the real
question here
are they bulletproof can they withstand
all kinds of different bombardment from
artillery and so on and so forth and
while it is cool they're lifting one of
our tanks other tanks German tanks can
weigh twice as much as these right so
like if they're kind of struggling and
it's all they can do to really lift up
this one as impressive as it is which
chance are they gonna stand against
Germans and so I'd result of that what
you also get is really the first
indication that none of these guys are
trained
unlike home Lander who was the first
homegrown superhero no pun intended in
so far that he was basically given
compound V in the womb and then became
the most powerful superhero on earth
these individuals were basically
injected now it wasn't as though the
injections worked right off the bat
that's one of the things that we've seen
davonne American would go through and
they would inject 200 humans with
compound v and those who didn't go
through these heinous and terrible side
effects they went on to become
superheroes basically we're at least
superheroes as they're being managed in
and essentially paid for by bought
American and so because these guys
aren't really trained what is up
happening is a couple of them basically
decide to fly recon and while it is kind
of impressive they can fly the big
takeaway from this is you guys probably
screwed up and when the questions asked
why it's because if you guys just jumped
into the air and then took off and did
some recon work and basically looked for
the Germans and then found them then
what makes you think the Germans didn't
see you and say what in the hell is that
there's people flying in the air let's
see where they came from and then
leading them back here to this entire
assortment of soldiers who at the moment
are not prepared for conflict and so if
the Germans come showing up on their
doorstep and they're they're ready to
march and they're ready to fight and
they open fire these guys are gonna get
caught with their pants down and that's
exactly what happens for the Germans
sitting in the bushes immediately open
fire and what you get is this bloodbath
that for all the glitz and glamour of
the avenging squad and what they can do
and how powerful and capable they are
they get shot all the pieces right one
of them flies into the air gets hit by
the propeller of a plane gets chopped to
pieces another guy gets run over by a
tank I mean it's an absolute massacre
right not only that because these guys
were caught unawares they're all
basically slaughtered right so Greg
Mallory is the only survivor left right
he's the only one left alive and so the
result of that is that when he's there
in one of the guys has only been cut in
half and asked for help Rick Mallory
takes out a grenade throws that the guy
walks away and it just kind of like you
guys are more of a problem than your
work and that's where Greg Mallory's
hatred of superheroes began I really I
would really say hatred so much as his
distrust and dislike of superheroes
began because what
did is he kept one of the pieces of
evidence that somebody said you know
avant American consolidate is showing
that bought American had ties to the
Battle of the Bulge the issue is that in
the aftermath of this bought American
washed their hands on everything right
and we knew that we knew that's what
they did
they bought American in the aftermath of
the Battle of the Bulge and the way that
a lot of things in World War two had
gone south
they basically quit they basically kind
of walked away and said okay we're
essentially done here now one of the big
things to come out of this and really
kind of tying into some real-world
history here is that in the aftermath of
World War Two we basically got the
formation of the CIA now it wasn't it
was an immediate it wasn't really until
the National Security Act of 1947 that
was passed that basically created the
National Security Council and the CIA
but during this whole set of events here
Greg Mallory was there when the CIA was
in the process of being formed but one
of the things that had gone on is that
there were particular individuals here
who were aware of the danger or least
the idea of Vaud american creating
superheroes and sending them out there
now when he basically kind of goes to
this bit of an explanation about the spy
game he's really talking more about the
United States and Russia Russian
involvement right because after the end
of world war two you end up going into
the cold right and the Cold War was the
the reason why it's called that is
because there was no actual war between
the United States and what was at that
point the USSR right we didn't actually
go to war with each other instead what
we got were a whole bunch of proxy
conflicts right so the soviet-afghan war
in the 1980s the Vietnam War there were
a lot of these conflicts there were an
attempt of the United States to expand
its sphere of influence with capitalism
and the USSR to expand its sphere of
influence with communism what this
really shows us is the idea that the spy
game was alive and well insofar as Greg
Malory what basically became the CIA the
the spy agency of the United States
sitting people into Russia only to find
them basically disappearing and
vanishing and so on and so forth all
that's really kind of background stuff
to say here the things that he did as
part of the early days of the CIA but
seen bought American for what it was and
believing it bought American was
exceedingly dangerous this all comes to
a head when he reads an article in The
Washington Post about how what bought
American is basically done is created
something called the crime fighter's
incorporated which was later on to be
you know become known as payback but
essentially it was a recreation of the
avenging squad the idea that it was
essentially like soldier boy the the
steel knight lario eagle the archer man
bought buzzer crimson countess all the
people who were there during World War
two and as soon as Greg Malory saw this
what he basically realized is that what
American
use the the Battle of the Bulge as a
testbed can its work and then realizing
their mistakes essentially clean slated
the whole thing wiped any evidence of
their involvement aside from that one
little piece of fabric that Gregg
Mallory has so nobody really seemed to
know that they were involved at least
nobody in the public face and very few
military officials actually knew and so
then when they suddenly show up here
with the crime fighters incorporated
there's no one there to say hey that was
the same group during World War two and
no was a total catastrophe nobody was
there for that and so the result is that
it really sort of begins to piss them
off because they get some of the
question of if fought Americans screwed
up so disastrously in that regard how
are they going to screw up now right
like how bad are things going to get now
and so what he sort of doing was making
phone calls sort of getting a hold of
people and ultimately ended up coming
across you know these these various
instances when Vaude american was still
engaging in various arms and armament
things like that their guns were misfire
and so on and so forth getting soldiers
killed during the vietnam war and that
was particularly important because if
you guys recall the entire Vietnam
conflict that we ended up having the
legend that's where his first son died
and that's why he harbored a resentment
towards flawed American right because
mod American were the ones who were
creating the weapons their desire to cut
corners got his son killed and he'd been
working against the the company ever
since which was a huge blow because he
knew everything right he was part of
victory comics become a book arlov on
American so he knew the true side of the
stories and then the stories they were
supposed to tell but what he basically
done is he had made Rick Mallory aware
of a guy named Vogel bomb now Vogel bomb
as you guys know was the guy who created
compound V and so the idea of Greg
Mallory was okay if we're going to use
the resources of the CIA to do this we
cannot make it look like the CIA's
actually involved and so in one of the
most brilliant maneuvers ever what he
did is he leaked the identity of Vogel
bomb to the corporate competitors of on
American knowing that if they couldn't
get him to their side they were gonna
kill him and because of the fact that he
couldn't be swayed to their side they
basically sent assassins in there and
then using the assassins he tracked down
the location of Vogel bomb and then in
turn basically killed all the assassins
and then went to kill Vogel bomb himself
ultimately deciding that he couldn't do
it and so in order to use him as more of
an asset than anything else he kind of
gave a couple of instructions right and
this really comes off you know hot off
the heels of Dakota Bob the vice
president for a George Herbert Walker
Bush who ultimately of course in the
real world was President of the United
States and was as well the difference is
that in I believe Dan Quayle was the
vice president under George HW Bush now
I'm not going to swear to that but
Dakota Bob in
being vice president instead and Dakota
Bob of course ended up winning the
presidency but as the vice president he
was the one that essentially sanctioned
all this stuff right because nobody
really looks at what the vice
president's doing nobody really cares
right the vice president he's just an in
case guy right like in case something
happens to the president then the vice
president will do some things and like
he can basically sway the vote in
Congress and like aside from that nobody
really cares what the vice president can
or cannot do but what this did is it
allowed that right now to kind of
operate to a degree of his own accord
and so working alongside a vocal bomb
what he said was you're alive the CIA
knows you're alive the government's
going to try to use you so make compound
V do whatever is you have to do in order
for us to kind of continue this whole
scheme going on but when you make your
compound V make sure it takes like seven
to eight years to make one batch of it
and then make it just like ridiculously
expensive right like hundreds and
hundreds of millions of dollars if not
in the billions so the government simply
just cannot afford it right because the
one thing that Greg Mallory wanted to
avoid was the federal government
launching its own version of what bought
American was doing and so because of
that what is up happening is with vocal
bomb working alongside him he ultimately
ends up taking an injection of compound
V which of course is how he gets his on
his initial dose and then it goes
directly into billy butchers origin and
billy butcher is kind of given to us as
you know from Gregg Mallory is a guy who
was in his younger days we're not really
given a whole lot about his history
which is to say like his childhood and
all that kind of stuff not the same way
we are with like Frenchy and the female
and mother's milk or anything like that
but basically he was a guy who had a who
had a grudge
he held a grudge against the seven
because of the fact that his wife had
been by his presumably homeland ur and
in the child she gave birth to ended up
killing her when it essentially clawed
itself from the inside out and so
because of that what Billy butcher
really showed here was a kind of ability
to operate in the form of espionage and
spy tactics but to also be exceedingly
effective right Lee was very very good
at what he did but the initial charter
of what it was a billy but you were
supposed to do and the initial role of
Gregg Mallory was that they were really
going to more contain and control the
various superhero threats right it was
it was this idea of yes there are
superheroes out there we're basically
gonna find ways to make sure they don't
deviate too far out of line and if it
really comes to it then we'll kill him
right the killing them is a last-ditch
effort but it was really more of like a
reconnaissance
sort of organization a reconnaissance
bloc office what work team more or less
you know functioning as part of the CIA
there really wouldn't have anything to
do with anybody from there what it did
is it essentially went into the pose
9:11 landscape and of course as you guys
know from the previous videos that we've
done when it came to 911 things went
belly-up and the seven you know the the
various Air Force pilots who were going
to shoot down some of the planes they
were called off and the seven stepped in
probably to screw the whole thing up
right like two bunker the whole thing
which resulted in the deaths of hundreds
of people when it didn't necessarily
need to the idea was to use the seven to
show that they could you know intervene
in a time like this in a crisis like
this and then kind of bring things to a
peaceful solution insofar as grabbing
the plane bringing it back down to the
ground getting everybody evacuated
killing those individuals who were on
board that were continue to inflict harm
and then call it a day to demonstrate it
could be as much a tried and true of
credible threat to those individuals who
are marching against the interests of
the United States more or less bad guys
and then in turn also be like
humanitarians because it didn't really
work out the dangers of the seven were
put in full force and showing that
bought American doesn't really care who
they harm or how those individuals get
harmed so long as their own mission ends
up continuing on at the same time
because of billy butchers animosity
towards the seven building on top of
what he'd seen as the seven engaging in
and the kind of recklessness that bought
american really seemed to display kind
of pushed billy butcher more and more to
the edge where billy butcher was really
kind of recruiting the rest of the boys
and then the team itself began to evolve
in such a way where it was we're waging
a war on the various superheroes who
were out there will kill them you know
if we if we can get away with it
otherwise we'll use them for information
but the boys team as it exists now is
not what it was originally envisioned to
be and naturally the way gregg Mallory
kind of laments and regrets the whole
thing that in his mind what he did is
exactly what the CIA has historically
done by the CIA has usually created its
own enemies right Osama bin Laden and
the soviet-afghan war of the 1980s is a
perfect example right backing the
Mujahideen holy warriors teaching him
how to shoot how to fight giving him
weapons things like that and then when
the soviet-afghan war ended then it
turned into okay all these people that
we that we basically armed and taught
how to fight now want to attack us right
so creating our own enemies over and
over and over again you know the whole
idea of the history between the United
States and Iran is a result of the
United States getting involved in
creating its own enemies it's what the
US has historically almost always done
and so because of that Greg Mallory kind
of looks at that and says I've
essentially done the exact same thing
I've created a monster
it's really how he looks at Billy
butcher and so it's really a point where
the boys cannot be contained and
controlled anymore why they can't be
reined back in they're too far gone and
Gregg Mallory kind of hits out here is
this entire thing is heading on a
collision course right where he sends
Billy butcher out to eliminate vogel
bomb it's kind of the last bit of
information there what this does is it
shows the idea that there's a collision
course right the boys are inexorably on
a course to face off against the seventh
and there's gonna be a lot of people who
die right there's there's really no way
around that
because Billy butcher doesn't want it
any other way this is Billy butcher's
own personal war and he's using the boys
as a means to fight it as a result of
that you know when brick Mallory really
kind of spills all these beans to Huey
really kind of tells Huey about all
these different things he recalls him
for what it is and he says I think this
whole thing of like some veteran in this
this whole you know was me and I made
some mistakes you know and then things
are beyond my control now I think it's
just an act you know he's like I think
you're a sham I think you're a failure I
think you're you're a half-measure
right you're a guy who wanted to get in
you get involved in the experiment and
you tried it and it didn't really work
the way that you wanted to and the
result is that you know it's a little
beyond your control and you just want to
kind of scapegoat Billy butcher when you
could reel them back in and you could
try to find a way to control them but
it's just too hard it's just too damn
hard so you're just gonna wash your
hands of it and run away and call it a
day right so we'd have really kind of
calls them a coward and a failure and so
what it does is it leads to Huey
traveling back to starlight and
basically spilling the beans about
everything and saying I work for the CIA
I work for the boys our whole purpose in
this this whole situation is to track
down superheroes we've killed him we've
beat them within an inch of their lives
we've done all kinds of heinous things
but it's to basically push you guys and
pressure you guys put the screws to you
guys to the point where you guys lash
out and the world will see you for what
you really are but the problem is that
with this being the case when you corner
a rabid animal like that it gets violent
and that's exactly what's going to
happen here right that's Huey's biggest
fear as long as a full-scale war is
going to break out between the
superheroes and humanity that the
superheroes are going to ally themselves
with home Lander and then in turn
because homeland is going to see the
boys as an extension of humanity that
homeland is going to wage war against
humanity right so it's gonna be this
massive global war between the
superheroes and the militaries of the
world and everything is going to go to
pot and so the stance is we have to kind
of basically try to find a way to stop
that from happening as it was kind of
interesting because it's the first time
that you really get into like an actual
directional plot for the story the
overall plot has been superheroes are
bad and we have to contain them you know
and that's basically been it but now we
have a forward direction which is pretty
legit but with that being said guys
remembering this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explained wish
you guys are the sub button to become
part of the rob4
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later
please okay I want to give a shout out
to Kyle be David Joseph Ben John h aj
Matt and Jeff are John H lean and mean
which is an awesome name Jason see
Austin s Austin Asia Joey M Steven Z
Austin be Adam K and Genesis 9 16
remember guys you can send me messages
and I'll run off whatever your message
is at the end of the video so long
there's nothing crazy but if you want to
put a message in there send me an email
Rob at Robert Jefferson calm and if
you're one of these people who get
shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch you guys
[Music]